you've done so much before you became a
stand-up comedian so it's baffling how
you kind of fell into it because you you
like
you're a swimmer yeah right you were
like really training to be a swimmer
yeah I started training for the Junior
Olympics and two days later I got in a
car accident and quit swimming
and was the driver drunk yeah the drunk
it was a drunk driver it was it was this
uh program at George school I think it
was so I lived in Philadelphia in the
suburbs of Philadelphia and my neighbors
were already doing Junior Olympics and
training in this program so they were
like why don't we we'll take you there
and so I had gone in my initial
consultation and I loved this one
program so you'll go in the morning and
a night at night I mean my life would be
so different if I didn't get in that
[ __ ] car accident because
I just had a lot of
um I was just a creative person and I
had an athletic build I don't know if
you can see the soldiers I was good at
swimming naturally pretty good you're a
really good swimmer obviously I was
pretty good at it yeah feeding him like
but I mean I needed to train I was like
raw Italian I wasn't like
you know I I could have gotten really
good did you love it at the time I
couldn't stand it it was so boring but I
didn't want a theme Here you you date
guys you hate them yeah you do Sports
you hate them but now but that was that
was old me and knew me I I check him I
have a meeting with myself every morning
what do I need what do I want how do I
feel and it but it was a long process to
learn that like I would even matter in
my own life like I just would just kind
of get taken places and so what would
the the the accident the car accident
left your foot injured so you couldn't
swim anymore yeah so I would which would
have been a long training process and I
didn't like it and that was I was 12
about to turn 13 when that happened so I
was ready to start smoking and drinking
and that's when I really started you
turn the wrong corner right corner for
my job now
foreign